have to showcase this just this hose and
the metal I got saddest thing I've ever
seen
that's good that's good that's good
that's good it's our table it's a
classic just let it go
nice touch he's gonna get wet now
multicolored what all right so uh
welcome to our double our makes tie-dye
I've never tie-dyed anything in my life
we really never know I grew up poor like
we couldn't even afford shirts let alone
color I was poor as a child not an ounce
of food was put in my body I eat grass
we didn't even have grass I didn't have
a long I had real nutrition I would have
grown ten times your height my potential
was never reached sadly so we're gonna
tie dyed zits because I'm trying to
relive all the childhood memories I
never had and those are the only reason
we have ideas so here's some
instructions we don't need those we have
friendship that's the power of tie-dye
it's made with your friends will lead
the way whoever makes tie day alone is
sad and a loser so it got lower cut
meant bigger pants but seriously
die die is a dangerous thing
if you mix the wrong chemicals at the
wrong times it will explode
hence the gloves yes yes so we can't
have any leakage you're right thank you
you want to feel I want to feel
let me feel so no let me feel something
you like me to put yours on slave your
fingers let me ban you you guys have to
have some sort of gift or clip that
makes it super sexual that we've
promised ourselves nerve damage in the
near future what we have here is the
assembly oh come on you yeah you want a
one-inch punch how's it feel like
nothing like a bee landed on this so as
you could probably tell we can't do
anything normally ever here no your face
never thought about any decision I've
ever made
I don't think that Amy spent so much
time assembling this perfectly so color
coordinate oh my god so the reason we've
got these all assembled nice like this
is because we're not just gonna do this
normally oh no we've got three shirts we
got three men we got and we got tie-dye
so with this we're gonna make these
shirts but we're not gonna do it with
our eyes we're gonna do it with our
souls like making love your eyes your
body are you making a balaclava yeah so
as you can see I cannot see you want me
to hold it again yeah no you've got it
in front of me no easier in the way my
large sole all right pussyfooting around
we are gonna tie it up were using the
dry method and that means that we're
gonna be tie dyeing these shirts dry
we've all got our blindfolds on right
uh-huh yeah okay we can't see a thing
right cool everyone pick up their shirts
okay no peeking
no nothing yeah there's a bucket of
water
the bucket water as far away from you as
possible to keep going man yeah keep
going what do you what are you doing I
can't see well you got found a wall
alright that's not helpful
uh-huh uh-huh all right good job man all
right thanks man all right let's all
raise our blindfolds like just for a
little bit okay cool
all right good once we put him down then
that's it we'll call it like from there
but overall I don't know a lot of Thai
Thai techniques we've got rubber bands
here it has something to do with the
colors but the most important thing is
when you grab a color try to put it back
in the same place you got it
because every one look at the colors
memorize this because this is the only
chance we get to look at this okay
should we should we put the water up on
the table first what oh wait we don't
need them we're doing the dry that's
right yeah it's like a technique right
it'll help it run or something so if we
want to use the water will have to
navigate to it yeah yeah seven u17 yes
mr. seven yeah seven sounds good three
two one huh what what it was just me
push me I'm feeling all those memories
from camp flooding back to me I'm
feeling the memories of me living in a
dumpster from age three age four and a
half but time was hard to keep track of
people only threw out calendars every
once in a while I did this block party I
mean I had a block I had blocks I wasn't
that poor you know they threw a brick
construction yard
while you know okay what are you already
on the dyeing face yeah Oh God how
squeeze did you SQUOZE okay nice clothes
you're trying to crush a baby's skull
not you know better not that hard think
of think of trying to squeeze out a
little bit of toothpaste ah
I felt splatter on me did it come out
okay all right that's a good that's a
good benchmark that's a good benchmark
there's a big gap here weird this one
good that's black unless you took like
oh I'm taking a chance
uh-huh and I'm going to the water the
problem with tie-dye is it stains real
good staining is really the main fear
we're dying what I felt like there were
a lot more bottles here before
[Music]
no I don't know have my fingers leap
through all my fingers through oh I need
new glove well no one's gonna tell you
how much time do we got okay all right
that's all just a little just a like a
sweet dab sorry I just touched you with
my shirt 30 seconds I think mine's done
I don't know I did the water I did I did
some smoosh on it I think I did
everything I wanted to do what are you
envisioning before we all bring up our
blindfolds
what are we envisioning that we have I
think mine is a spider with multicolored
legs
well it's not about colors first I feel
like other than the shade we could try
and figure out the colors based on where
we reached I feel what some yellow okay
red and blue and a purple and I think I
grab black at the end but I hope not I
was trying to go for every color of the
rainbow I've made a black shirt I think
yes I was close I don't think oh I CLO I
got a little green in there did you get
the closet I don't know I tried you see
it's not as colored as I would have
liked it but you know kind of like it's
got a minimum people do it mine's a very
white shirt with a lot of different I
like it cuz you've got like stuff on the
sleeves yeah I think me doing a lot of
water maybe the spread happen yeah but
this sounds cool you guys we have a
fully colored shirt come we'll be right
back when they're dry in the meantime
here's a word from our sponsors I said
get ready to cop scene change we're in a
different place but we got our shirts
and our shirts are dry check them out
this is a shirt that's a shirt this is a
shirt so why aren't you spinning am I
supposed to spend yeah you wrote is
arrived what do I have to spin well the
show's all shirt yeah good thanks been
working out that's good thank you are
you gonna compliment my back either oh
yeah it's good
right so let's judge them um that one
it's not bad but it lost integrity of
the shape it was in like I can't tell
like if it was a spiral if it was a
circle out that's the only thing I'll
say about plus the rubbings let me see
the back
yeah that you got like a lot of rubbings
back here it doesn't entirely look
intentional I personally think marks is
the best yeah you sucks I could see that
like that being a mass-produced like
just design there's too much green it's
bad music awesome
very great yeah that's what happened
when I dunked it in it just all soaked
up the colored man it's too much water
mm-hmm yeah but not bad like for my
first I died I bet I wouldn't have been
able to do something that looked good if
I tried and could see cuz I literally
just it just happens to turn out this
way but it works
I think the chaos is what made it really
special okay your sleeves are on point
if you could like cut those sleeves off
put it on to just a plain white t-shirt
that actually might look really cool it
wouldn't be worth it by any stretch of
the imagination but it looked cool why'd
you rub it man because they tied your of
it don't rub it don't rub it don't rub
it
hey stop rubbing cut it up get some help
anyway thank you so much for watching
this has been wingless and dingus dingus
over here Craig gameplay swing us over
here Apocalypto underscore 12 on twitch
I have been markiplier thank you so much
for watching check out other cool stuff
we've made in the description below and
let us know of other ideas you have
thanks again and as always we'll see you
bye bye
care to spin I'm trying to spinning dear
spirals